started really in the first half of the
19th century when first batch of your
graduates went to China in the 1830s as
educators and missionaries so Peter
Parker collaborated with Liang Kuan who
was a Chinese artist and they did some
very explicit documentation of diseases
which became a very valuable source for
training young medical students and in
fact for training medical students in
the West starting in 1850 when the first
Chinese student called the yen wing who
entered your college and graduated in
1854 he then went back to China and
persuaded ting court to bring more
students back to yell until New England
and those student later and played a
very influential role in modernization
of China in 1917 when freedom was
transformed from a college to a
university its founding president ledum
where it was a year graduated class of
1899 leading we played a very
influential role in establishing the
university and introduced lots of yours
philosophy in running the university and
that was very influential in
establishing fudan as one of the best
universities in China and of course
since then there are lots of our
exchange activities have occurred and
for example in modern days in 2003 yo
established a year of fudan
developmental biology center in the
center has played a very important role
was in promoting fidence research in
developmental biology and also in
expanding our research here a year the
year china association which was
established in 1901 and now over more
than a hundred years now
this association has placed a very
important role in training teachers and
medical practitioners in China as an
exemplary case of placing their place
schools in chanza a big city in the
middle part of China and this continuous
training has been going on now for over
100 years and today is still going west
John it's amazing to see that you know
there are actually 96 exchange programs
going on between Yale and China
involving 26 different departments a
year and 44 universities in China this
relationship is truly beneficial to both
sides to China by having this
relationship it benefited tremendously
from the most advanced thinking
knowledge and practice and moreover yer
also helped China to trend of a number
of very important leaders in diverse
fields of society and for you the first
advantage is that the students and
scholars from China on your campus they
directly contribute by their talent to
heroes research intellectual power and
cultural life by tapping into their vast
resource yours research activities have
further opportunities to flourish
channel really is the largest country in
the world representing nearly one-fourth
of the world so that give us a direct
and a privileged opportunity to invest
here and study their world by training
some of the leaders in China over
centuries you're truly exercised its
influence to that very important part of
the world and that means very important
to polishing Yale has to lay a group
global leader in higher education
you